you'll have about 10 seconds until you
can start talking
okay
okay good evening everyone and welcome
to this evening's virtual meeting of
uh tonight's planning committee my name
is councillor peter richards and i will
be chairing
the meeting um i do have a number of
housekeeping items to run
through very quickly if i may so please
bear with me while i do that
um first of all in line with the legal
requirements the agenda for this
planning committee b
was published prior to annual council
however
due to the changes to the operation of
the council's planning committees
uh that were agreed at annual council it
is necessary for this meeting to proceed
under the revised terms of reference for
the newly formed single planning
committee
it was also agreed at the annual council
to introduce a maximum
three-hour duration for planning
committee meetings with the exception
being that where consideration of any
application has commenced 30 minutes or
more prior to the three-hour cut-off
that will continue until that item is
determined any application that does not
meet this condition
will automatically be deferred to any
future planning committee meeting
so with all that in mind welcome to the
first meeting of this newly formed
planning committee
members you will have already been uh
provided with yet to get for virtual
meetings
and advance this meeting you've all been
through many of them now so you know how
things work but just to remind you
please make sure your device
is fully charged or is charging please
mute your microphones i cannot stress
that enough please meet
your microphones when you are not
speaking if you want to speak please
indicate
in the chat bar um and you will be
called to speak at the right
time um when you are invited to address
the committee please ensure the
microphone is switched back on again
and immediately switched off when you
are done um if for any reason you
encounter any i.t problems causing you
to drop out
of this virtual meeting then do please
make your best endeavors to rejoin as
quickly as possible
if you're unable to rejoin uh then you
will have been deemed to have left the
meeting at that point and the meter will
continue provided it remains
corrupt there are two numbers in our
chat now one friday help desk and one
for committee services
that you will be able to call should you
have any issues they will be able to
help you um for members of the public uh
just to confirm that
prior to the meeting commencing uh we
did
ensure that all um committee members uh
in attendance did confirm in the
presence of the
legal officer that they can see and hear
proceedings and that they have read
their reports in full
that's the housekeeping done um so uh i
will
now very quickly introduce you to our
officers
so we have and banks from committee
services we also have
online liz jaworska and olivia quinn who
will be supporting
uh both again from committee services
ross chambers from our legal uh council
or is our legal counsel
uh erin weatherston planner and neil
hempstead who is
senior planner we also have richard
gardner who
is our planning manager for this evening
richard i believe you have a statement
you'd like to make
thank you chair um just to confirm that
my role is to provide
impartial advice and to assist members
in their decision taking
thank you marvelous thank you very much
for members of the public that are
listening now and will be registered
registered to speak when you are called
to speak if you could please press star
six that will unmute your microphone you
will then be able to be heard from the
committee we will confirm we can hear
um and i will run through um prior to
you speaking uh the
the rules of engagement when it comes to
to making your comments
so let's move straight into our
committee meeting
um first on the agenda is apologies for
absence
and banks could you give us the
apologies please yes
chairman we've got apologies from
councillors crump mills
and parry and we've got councillor
curtis with us this evening
and he will not be participating he will
be observing
lovely thank you very much um and
disclosure
disclosures of interest members do we
have any disclosures of
interest if you could please indicate in
the chat
uh while you are doing that i will say
that the first item
on the agenda 1901 243 ful heart of
england farms is in my ward however i am
here with an open mind
and will remain on the committee to
determine it
um i can see no one else indicating
that they have uh any disclosures of
interest so should we shall move to the
minutes of previous meetings can we
confirm that the minutes
held on 12th of august and 26th of
august are an accurate and fair
reflection
um a quick thumbs up or show of hands on
my screen
would be perfect i can see lots of
thumbs up so i shall take that as a yes
and we will sign those
at a later date right so our first
application then which as i've already
mentioned is the heart of england's farm
1901 243 ful
members you'll note in the update sheet
that the objection
from cleveland parish council was a
reason for referral to the committee
uh the parish council have not
registered to speak and
under our new terms of reference and
in fact under the previous terms of
reference as well that would normally be
delegated to officers
what we do need is confirmation from all
members that
can be delegated so i propose that
that is the case that is delegated could
i have a seconder please
counselor jennings has secondly crikey
everyone seconding at the same time
council jennings do you want to say
anything or could you just verbally
confirm that you are seconding that
motion
counselor counselor journey so verbally
verbally confirming that i'm second in
the motion
fabulous thank you very much um in that
case we will go straight to a vote on
that
um given i can see how many seconders
are in my chat i can see where this is
going
uh i will start councillor richards four
councillor kendall councillor kendall
for councillor fleming
chancellor fleming for
councillor adam councillor adam four
councillor dixon councillor dixon for
councillor edin that's the reading four
that's the henshaw phone
and so hence finlab stein
and councillor jennings councillor
jennings ball
that's awful with one abstention
chairman marvelous thank you in that
case committee results
to delegate two officers the
determination of
location zero one two four three fpl
uh which is a quran okay
um if we could thank mr groning for
signing in mr running you are uh
no longer required this evening but
thank you for registering to speak
thank you for logging in
i am getting quite a lot of feedback so
if all members could ensure that their
microphones are in fact computers then
i've just
i've just muted all of the speakers that
are in because i think it might be one
of them
marvelous thank you very much okay we
will move then to our next application
which is application 201249 ful
glendale in warmington our presenting
officer is erin weatherston
erin over to you
thank you chairman i'll just bring a
presentation up on screen
please can you confirm everyone can see
that we can thank you
the application site lies to the north
of bradley village within the
countryside
the site lies within the cotswolds area
of outstanding natural beauty
and overlooks a valley to the north
where the land falls away
the application site is outlined in red
just here
and includes a single story dwelling
with garden to the front
and to the rear and access to the west
of the site
and a single story outbuilding property
forms one of a number of dwellings sent
to the north of camp lane
the site shares the access with the
neighbouring dwellings just to the
northwest of the site
planning permission is sought for the
demolition of the existing dwelling and
outbuilding
and the erection of a replacement
dwelling with associated works
this slide shows existing floor plans
and elevations of the bungalow and
attached flat roof garage on the site
see the bungalow just here
and the flat roof garage to the north
west of this site
the property is simple in design with
pitch roof and single story rear
projection which you can see just here
the existing property currently has
three bedrooms of accommodation
and to the right of the slide it's a
photograph taken from looking at the
front elevation of the property with the
outbuilding visible
to the left of the image and the shared
access the middle photograph shows the
side elevation of the property
and the bottom photograph is looking
from the garden back towards the rear
elevation of the existing dwelling on
the site
planning permission was granted in 2017
for alterations and extensions to the
existing dwelling
this is an extent permission the 2017
floor plans are shown to the left of
this slide
just here and the proposed plans for
replacement dwelling are shown to the
right
the key changes to the floor area
proposed over and above the extant
permission
include an enlarged basement area which
is subterranean shown approximately here
on the plan
and first floor accommodation shown
approximately here
both extent permission of a proposed
replacement dwelling include four
bedrooms and parking for three vehicles
with two parking spaces just here at the
front of the property
and parking within the proposed garage
existing access to the west of the site
is proposed to be retained
as part of the new development
this slide shows the 2017 approved
elevations to the left
and the proposed plans to the right so
2017 just here
the key changes the replacement dwelling
over and above the extent permission
include
alterations to the elevations in terms
of design and increasing the ridge
height by approximately 0.5 meters
alterations to the front element just
shown here you can see the difference
between the existing
a change to the link along the west of
the site
which would now be single story and
alterations to the rear projection which
you can see just here which will be
higher
than the extent permission to the rear
the proposed balcony is proposed to be
retained
and that's just shown here and you can
see the balcony on the adjacent property
to the side there is a change in ground
levels across the site you can see that
on the plans as the land slopes away
to the north of the site
this slide shows a number of photographs
of the existing site the top two images
were taken looking from the road and
show the existing access
just here front garden area existing
dwelling
and the outbuilding and this photograph
is taken looking across and see the
neighboring property just here
the images along the bottom of the slide
were taken from the garden looking back
across the site towards the rear
elevation
single story rear projection and the
ridge of the existing property
and looking across at the outbuilding
from the garden the change in levels are
visible
across the photographs
this slide shows a number of photographs
of the relationship between the
application site and the closest
neighbor ridge house
the top left image shows existing
relationship along the boundary which
was taken from within the application
site
the top right image was taken looking
back towards the neighboring property
you can see
rehabitable openings and balcony area
just here the application site just here
to the right
the bottom left image was taken from the
access track you see the existing
outbuilding
on the site looking back towards the
neighbouring property
and the final image on this slide was
taken from the rear guard and looking
towards the neighbouring property
the final slide has a number of
photographs taken from within the rear
garden of the application site
this photograph is taken back looking
towards the outbuilding showing the
change in levels across the site the
access is just here
this photograph is taken looking across
and panning around from the application
site to the north and moving across to
the north and you can see the lower
level land
in the valley beyond for a number of
updates for this application which have
been circulated on the update sheet
it is recommended that planning
permission be granted subject to the
conditions and notes outlined within the
officer report
thank you
erin thank you very much for that and we
will move straight to our first speaker
who is mr mark burstel i'm assuming
cancer mark versus
of warmington and also parish council mr
bursal are you there can you hear us
if you press star 6 on your keypad
you will be unmuted
yes good evening good evening welcome
um so i don't know if you've done this
before but you'll have three minutes to
speak
um and once you've finished if you could
stay on the line for any questions from
members we would also give you a
30-second warning
before your time is up um aside from
that
you're free to start whenever you're
ready so over to you could i just ask
um erin to put up the photograph that i
requested please
i confirm that's on screen now thank you
the proposal brings the eastern wall of
the development its foundations and the
major basement excavation much
closer to ridge house it will run along
the line of the fence to the right of
the picture you are being shown
rather than the line of the existing
building which is also visible on the
right
there is a gap of just 2.5 metres
between the west wall of ridgehouse
and the east wall of the proposed new
development
this gives rise to significance and
concern about the physical effect on the
rich house foundations
and as a principal reason for our
objection
glendale is highly visible from the
b4086 roadway
contrary to the applicant's claim it is
also very
prominent on the skyline when viewed
from the north and the proposal is so
large it will dominate that view
all this within the cotswold aonb
the recommendation to grant disregards
at least five
important sections of the course
strategy setting a very dangerous
precedent for other future applications
the planning office's case is based on
two incorrect conclusions
one that the scale and design of the
replacement dwelling
does not cause inappropriate harm to the
character of the area
or to neighbouring properties we
strongly disagree
and maintain that the proposal fails
this test and is therefore contrary to
policy as10
paragraph f two based on concerns about
the roof structure
and insulation levels in the existing
building the planning officer concludes
that the existing building is not
suitable for retention
in line with policy cs20
this is a distraction because the roof
will be replaced anyway
and the insulation issue can be readily
addressed as part of the approved
development
we therefore strongly dissocrately with
the planning officer's conclusion
the building to land area ratio of the
proposal is excessively high
this is another very dangerous precedent
to be allowing
it is vital that the shared access be
kept open at all times for other users
and for the emergency services no
construction traffic should be allowed
to use or obstruct the shared access
so to summarize we're concerned about
the effect of the proposal on the
immediate neighbors
and about the visual impact this
proposal will have within the setting
of the aonb we are concerned that the
recommendation to grant
flies in the face of established
published core strategy
on so many points and the very dangerous
precedent
that this sets we are concerned that the
recommendation the grant is made in
spite of well argued objections from
cpre
the district councillor to parish
councils and several local residents
thirty seconds concerned two about the
dangerous precedent that would be set by
allowing such a large development
on such a small piece of land the new
development is significantly higher
and will deprive light from ridge house
the 25 degree test fails on two out of
three windows
a fact overlooked by the planning
officer this is a very large and
expensive development
which raises the question of the
long-term intention of the applicant
and known developer of apartment blocks
in the banbury area
it sounds like that was perfectly timed
for mr verstal there
members do we have any questions for mr
burstol
while you type into the chat if you do i
would just ask very quickly
um mr russell the the property uh that
is next door to the this
this application site can you tell me
when that was built it's either been
extraordinarily well maintained or it's
a relatively
recent build could you give me a rough
idea of when it was
positioned there it was um
it was renovated and extended
um i would think about five years ago
but the original property
um many years old okay
that's lovely thank you very much um
there are no uh no one's
uh mentioned in the chat that they have
a question for you so
um that is it thank you very much please
uh do mute yourself again with star six
um or if you prefer to hang up and
you'll be able to continue watching
through our online portal um but thank
you very much
thank you for your contribution this
evening uh we will move then to our
second speaker
uh who is jane cashmore and mr
sadiq who is our applicant are you both
there again if you can press star
six to unmute yourselves
hi there yes yes we're both here it
sounds like
marvelous uh now who is um
jane i'm assuming that you're gonna be
doing most of the speaking and mr sadiq
is here to answer questions is that
correct pretty much so and we're going
to share the three minutes between us mr
speaks going to go first
take the approximate first 40 seconds or
so i'll then finish
off and i have got some slides which
will be relevant for when i'm speaking
okay the slides have been pulled up in
front of us now so we're on slide one
um what we'll do is if you're if you're
comfortable with this if mr sadiq goes
first
do you want me to give you a warning
when he's done or should we just sorry
when there's four seconds up or just let
him crack on
then you can have a speak and we'll give
you a 30 second warning for the three
minutes at that stage
is that easier yeah yes mr speaker goes
and then i'll just follow on and just
give me a warning near the end
thank you okay so uh mr sadie whenever
you're ready
you please do start good evening thank
you for the opportunity of uh
giving for me to speak uh my name is mr
sedek i'm the year
i'm the applicant uh the proposed
development development
developing is to be self-built for
myself i think the officer report is
very comprehensive and covers all the
issues
the existing dwelling is it is an entire
state of repair and needs some
updating just as the neighboring
properties have already done
for example my neighbors at ridgehouse
have benefited from the extension
over placement ground and first floor
it's fully my intention to improve the
existing dwelling
i've already been granted planning
permission for the extension
and the current application proposes a
replacement dwelling as an alternative
while i would prefer prefer to construct
the paused replacement
replacement developing if commission is
not granted i will carry
out the existing approval thank you
most of the objections relate to size
and it's clear that the proposed
replacement dwelling is larger than the
existing dwelling
but that's not the end of the matter the
key material point is the existing
planning permission for extensions and
alterations
your officers have carefully considered
these in comparison to the proposed
replacement dwelling
and consider that it's a fallback
position to which significant weight
should be attached
on the screen there are a series of
slides which i'd like to explain which
compare the approved extensions to what
is now proposed
slide 1 is an aerial image from google
earth on this slide glendale is roughly
outlined in yellow
you can see the footprint of existing
glendale and it's smaller than a number
of other nearby dwellings
increasing the size of the footprint is
not out of keeping with other properties
in the locality
nor over development of the site slide 2
shows a side-by-side comparison of the
approved to the proposed ground floor
plan
the footprints overlap for the most part
slide three shows the amount shows the
approved and proposed front elevations
the majority of the additional floor
space proposed over and above that
already approved
is within the roof space or basement
slide four shows the neighbour's front
elevation taken from the highway
showing a similar glaze design feature
slide five shows the approved and
proposed side perspectives
in this image you can see that the
proposed side element is flat roofed
compared to the approved pitch roof
this results in a less bulky side
elevation
slide six shows rear elevation
comparisons again you can see less bulk
over the now proposed garage on
reviewing these
no material harm would arise from the
proposed replacement dwelling compared
to the existing permission
with regards to heritage a report by
warwickshire archaeology accompanied the
application
and considered dedicated heritage assets
within 500 metres
their report states these designated
heritage assets all lie some distance
from the site
and intervening vegetation prevents any
inter visibility
between the site and scheduled monument
lamprey camp
or registered park broadway grange no
associations historically shared in
their setting have been identified
as such the current proposals are not
considered to result in non-physical
harm to the designated heritage assets
i hope you're able to support your
officer recommendation to grant thank
you for listening
thank you both very much for that um we
have a question from councillor dixon
so council dixon if you would like to
fire away thank you chairman
uh mr ms cashmore um
the counselor for the parish council
mark burstall uh indicated that the main
reason for their objection was the
fear regarding the construction and
being so close
to the neighboring property
um i may be wrong but does the party
wall act come into place here in which
case i think that's something which we
would not
normally have involved in our planning
decisions
and you confirm if the party wall act
comes into play
i'm i'm not a building regulations
expert but i believe the
party wall act is relevant and i noticed
that
um a letter has been sent in um by a
structural engineer company i believe on
behalf of bridge house which does refer
to the party wall act
um so i believe that would be applicable
if any planning permission were to be
granted this evening
thank you very much i made the
assumption that you would be aware of
the building rigs but never mind thank
you indeed
okay thank you for that councillor dixon
um members are there any other questions
for either mr cashmore or mr sadiq
maybe a couple of seconds to type
i'm taking that silence as i know so um
both of you thank you very much for your
time and contribution this evening again
if you want to press star 6 and listen
on the phone or if you want to
join on our online portal that's
probably the easiest thing to do
but thank you again for your for your
contributions thank you
we will move thank you we will move now
to our
final speaker for this item who is
councillor fielding councillor fielding
are you ready
you have five minutes ready enable
marvelous you have five minutes don't
forget can erin put up
the first of my that's that is the view
across um from the
site towards um
the dacid hills um down in the valley
below
is also also also
um is a house that was
occupied by prince charles the first
during the civil war
and there is in fact on one of the
windows
he has uh scratched his name
it's wonderful what diamonds will do um
cs5 and the character you can see from
the the the ridge where this house is
set up
both ascot the m40 and even dacid from
the valley bottom
thus the visual aspect will be out of
keeping with the environment
the historical environment there are two
important
historical sites the battle of edge hill
which as i say ascot house was involved
in and
nadbury camp an iron age encampment
that is in close proximity
cs9 this covers attractiveness
sensitivity design
etc the design of the first development
falls short in all of these
groups it's too large for the plot and
it's not in keeping with the site
that's the neighboring property's garden
if could you put up the one with the
their number one site um please erin
no they're number one sorry i'm jumping
you around
no i just want the um google earth one
sorry just to confirm the satellite
image from the the original presentation
yes
john if you want to carry on well that
is good okay helpful otherwise
this view shows the applicant's
property um this is part of the garden
to the ridge
which wraps around the south the north
side of that property
so this will then be overlooked by that
property
um the the other picture
that i have it doesn't matter erin um
the next picture of mine
um shows the garage
which they intend to connect into the
property there
again it is the overview of the
neighboring property is
um rather in my uh opinion too large
cotswolds aonb the site is within the
area and design
does not enhance the character
as 20 i'm interested to know
how the planning officer believes that
the proposal is suitable on this
occasion
cs20c refers to the renovation of
existing buildings
which um and
csf e sorry the proposal will preserve
and enhance the character of the
locality and will not
unacceptable unacceptably distract
from the amenities of any neighboring
properties by
reason of loss of light the loss of
privacy
overbearing um and
over sorry i'm getting blind in my old
age but anyway there you go
um so there are a number of things under
as20 that
really it goes against what the officer
said and again
as um as
10f again the first house is not in
keeping with this category
it refers to harm to the neighboring
property
the final picture
if you could say will show which is um
one that you've already seen but the
windows here
and a door there um which
is will be overlooked by the neighboring
house
and also be loss of light and i believe
from uh what i've heard is that is
outside the
the ruling that is allowed so that i
rest my case
rather startedly on that
okay thank you very much cancer fielding
members do we have any questions for
cancer building at this point please
indicate in the chat if you do
i'm going to take that sciences and no
so john thank you very much sorry i
should say cancer feeling thank you very
much your contribution
this evening if you could mute yourself
please do feel free to stay on and watch
the
final parts of this thank you thank you
for that you did a lot better than um
counselor kettle who kept calling me mr
i thank you john
and that's very kind um so
uh do we have any questions for our
officer um any questions of
clarification or points of clarification
please again if you could indicate in
the chat that would be great
counselor jennings has one cancer
journey is over to you
um yeah so on the extinct uh permission
uh which is obviously a fallback option
here um
what difference in the size is there
between
that and the new plans in terms of
square metres
so in terms of um square meters
we've got the extent planning permission
uh the floor area
and let me just bring it up just having
a quick
look the footprint's 200 approximately
278 square meters and proposes 303
so in the officer report it looks at
what we've got from the existing
dwellings we have to assess under cs20
from the existing dwelling
to the proposed and but from the extent
permission
and there would be a reduction in volume
and an
increase in in floor area by
approximately 39
so there is an increase in floor area
but a lot of it is subterranean in the
basement level
excellent thank you very much thank you
erin um we have a question from
councillor dixon council dixon over to
you
uh thank you chairman uh erin i made
reference to the party wall act
uh with the agent um they weren't
qualified to answer that
i do believe this uh comes under
building regulations and therefore
although it was the greatest concern of
the parish councillor
who spoke um essentially if it is
building ranks and not planning
i'm assuming that we can particularly
ignore
concerns regarding the footings and the
actual proximity of that wall
subject only to loss of light and
overbearing
issues and secondly the update sheet
indicates that there's some um
uncertainty of some of the land
ownership
could you confirm if this is about the
the access strip which is by assumption
at least
thank you yes in terms of the party
warlock normally that covers
any sort of development along the
boundary that tends to be a civil matter
what can say is that this would require
building regulations because it is a
replacement dwelling due to the extent
of the works
and so we're considering planning
considerations as part of the officer
assessment
um in terms of the update sheet i can
confirm that the applicant has made us
aware that certificate c
would need to be served and because
they're not aware of all the owners of
the access of the site
that's my understanding so they would
need to publicize that to see if any
further owners came forward
thank you aaron thank you thank you both
we have another question from councillor
fleming so council flaming over to you
hi erin um sorry tony asked half of my
question so that's already been answered
um but the other thing is do you know
exactly how many
local residents have complained about
this or
raised objections so that um you know we
can get a feel for what the local people
think themselves
thank you we have received five
third-party comments in response to the
application
and four are summarized in the officer
report and the latest one came in on the
update sheet
and so it's a recent representation from
a property that's already put a
representation in already
okay thank you for that thank you there
both um
we did have a question lined up from
cancer kendall but i believe he has
had that answered already so um
counselor adam has just come in with a
last-minute question so counselor adam
over to you thank you sorry about the
last minute there
um i was just thinking um obviously
there you've identified in the reporter
and the
cs20 is um is an issue
but the fallback seems to be the aspect
that
um the the shifts the balance as it were
um essentially i'm just trying to
determine why that's
why that's so significant in being a
worse case than
what's being proposed as i think some of
the issues
of overbearing that have been raised by
by their local representatives seem to
be on
things like ridge height and then stuff
that may not be as much of an issue in
the fallback
uh position am i am i reading that wrong
sorry
i just seemed like applying such weight
to that one position to over
turn cs20 seems a bit uh misbalanced
from my point of view
so from officer's perspective in terms
of cs20 the test is whether or not the
dwelling would be significantly larger
and looked at impact
on amenity and visual impact um in this
case the extent planning permission is a
realistic fallback position so officers
have afforded that significant weight in
the assessment
and the conclusion looks at what what
they've got permission for at the moment
the increase in size and the bulk and
the mass
in terms of the relationship with the
neighboring property um officers are
satisfied that subject to conditions
and notes that there wouldn't be an
adverse impact on neighbouring
properties amenity which would
result in a refusal of the
recommendation from offers it's in terms
of the recommendation
the access along the side of the
property and if i just bring up the
slides it's quite a similar relationship
to the extent planning permission
um because
might be helpful just to to bring up the
powerpoint presentation
in terms of the relationship so this is
the existing extent permission the side
facing windows
are here so there's still built form
that's proposed in this area
and a single story rear projection as
part of the extent permission and
similarly
you've got the same relationship the
ridge would be slightly higher for the
main element and but there would be the
single story element as well
so it'd be a similar similar
relationship to the extent planning
permission
and and just to show you the floor area
as well in terms of
how that would relate to the neighboring
property over the boundary because the
windows are just here
so the officer recommendation is to
grant planning permission on that basis
lovely thank you councillor adams to
answer your question
yes thank you thank you marvelous okay
so um if there are no further points of
clarification we will move into
the debate who would like to go first
don't all jump at once
councillor jennings was first to come in
say council jennings please
begin
thank you chairman i know a lot of this
is due as a
seems to be to do with the visual
aspects i mean i
quite frankly i see very little
difference between this
and the house the big house next door
but
i mean i always think that when
so we should um
if we want to go against an officer's
decision we should have some very good
reasons for doing so
and i can see no material planning
reasons to go against the
officer's recommendations um
and quite frankly so therefore i just
like to propose that we grant the
application
lovely thank you very much councillor
jennings um just before we move to
councillor kendall i just want to
confirm that you are
proposing to grant um in line with the
recommendations on the
update sheet which include two notes is
that correct
that is correct perfect thank you very
much councillor kendall
over to you thank you chairman
uh i think councillor james beat me to
it really i'm looking through this and
then
the one thing that's really very clear
to me is i'm looking at the extant
permission that's already in place i'm
looking at the proposal
proposal before us and i'm struggling to
see any major differences i understand
that this is a demolition of the
existing dwelling and replacement
but in terms of footprint i accept it's
going to be bigger
but i can't see any material harm at all
in this so i'm more than happy to
second cancer jennings proposal
fabulous thank you very much for that um
would anyone else like to
take part in a debate at this point
please indicate in the chat to give a
couple of seconds
and if no one does um counselor adam
no to you thank you i mean i i'm not
going to sort of disagree
fundamentally i don't think there are
any major planning reasons
uh that i could propose to to refuse
this
but i i just feel slightly uncomfortable
with the justification
against something that it is essentially
on the basis of the question i asked
around it being not fully according with
policy cs20
and yet the justification being that the
the fallback is worse than
than what's proposed and i frankly i
think if i had the opportunity to
to ask the um parish councillor again
about some of these things these might
kind of
bring my point forward a bit more i
think
ultimately there's nothing that's going
to stop me from
from from from you know
allowing this to to go forward but
it does seem to be quite a fine balance
and may be
finer and seem to be suggested and i
think that the points that were made by
the ward member and the parish
councillor
uh should hold weight in that so i just
essentially just want to
make clear that i i'm sort of in support
of those the points that were made by
them
and i think this is quite a fine balance
uh
as it falls
okay lovely thank you very much for that
there are no further
members registered to or have indicated
they want to speak so we shall
move through to a vote um i am and
wholeheartedly in agreement with
councillor jennings and councillor
kendall
and therefore i will be voting
to grant in line with officer
recommendation on the update sheet
okay councillor kendall
councillor kennel four councillor
fleming
councillor fleming for councillor adam
councillor abstain
councillor dixon councillor dixon
for councillor eden
councillor eden uh abstain
okay councillor hensha seraphin
uh council andrew serafin epstein
councillor jennings councillor jennings
paul
that's five four chairmen with three
abstentions
marvelous thank you very much and um so
in that case
um the committee have resolved to grant
application 2001 249 full
in line with the officer's
recommendation and uh the update sheet
thank you very much everyone for that um
we are going to take a brief adjournment
while we call in our speakers
for the next item so if we could just
take three minutes
um three minutes will be all we should
need so
thank you very much
how are you on
just remind members that we are still
live and people can hear
chairman the speaker's in
fabulous that was quick um okay
so members um i'm assuming we're all
still sat in front of our screens
um so let's dive straight into our
next item which is uh application
reference twenty zero zero
four five four f u l uh three garden
rose squash lane stratfor upon even our
presenting officer is neil hamster
neal over to you thank you chairman
can everyone see my
screen at all we can
okay don't i'm assuming
is the screen still up there the
presentation's still up
i have just got a view of your good self
at the moment so okay i'm not sure what
happened there
let me uh
there we go is that better
that's the one thank you okay
thank you chairman um the application
site is shown
in the center of the screen um
on the black spot and just to give
members
a bit more detail so the application
site
is shown with the red line there and to
give some context
um as i said the application site is in
the center of stratford-upon-avon so
there is elizabeth house
furs garden and also the
relatively newly built care home
the application site is also located
within the stratford-upon-avon
conservation area and the proposal is
for the demolition of a single-story
structure
and construction of two story and first
floor side extensions
so just to give members a bit more
context the application site is there
and again elizabeth house the relatively
newly built care home
and fers garden
so just to give a little bit more
context
the application site is
is shown here in red
and the two areas either side of the
main two-story element which will become
apparent in the plans i show
shortly are where the two extensions are
going
the other properties which i'll make
reference to
both in the committee report and in this
presentation
are numbers two and four
garden row and one ely gardens to the
rear
so just to show the the proposal so
at the top of the of this slide is the
um
the dwelling as existing so it has
single story elements
and a two-story element in the center so
the proposal is to demolish
this area here and with a new two-story
extension and a new extension at first
floor level
built in this area here
looking at the side elevations they will
be
painted brick the front
elevations here will be faced in brick
to match the existing dwellings
with a cream render at the bottom and
this is the rear of the dwelling and
again
as existing here then you can see the
two extensions which are proposed
so in terms of floor plans
so existing here so this is the element
that i referred to
which was proposed to be demolished so
it's a kitchen and utility
and the replacement is effectively a
like for light with a kitchen and
utility there
so at first floor level there's a flat
two flat roofs
and so the first floor here will be an
additional bedroom
and at um on the other side
there will be the replacement of the
existing
bathroom with a storage area here a new
bathroom
and an ensuite bathroom down here
so just to give some context to that in
terms of photographs
this is looking this photograph here is
looking at the front elevation of the
property
so this is two garden row here that i
refer to
and it's just just worth looking and
just keeping that in your mind there
that that slope root which i'll make
roof which i'll make reference to in a
further slide
and this is the element which is
proposed to be demolished and replaced
as part of a two-story
extension going there so
this photograph is to the rear of the
existing
dwelling three garden row and to the
rear is
one ely gardens so the two
areas here where the cursors are where
the extensions
are proposed to go
and this is another photograph looking
at the front elevation of
the of the dwelling so you can see the
area there where the proposed first
floor
extension is going to go and that is the
side window
at number four now this
is this serves a bedroom and there is
another
secondary window which serves this room
but that is
obscure glazed as noted in the committee
report
and on the previous photographs i made
reference to the
sloping roof which you can see there so
this is number two
and this is also a side window which
will face the extensions which serves
a bedroom window and that is the only
window which serves the bedroom so
members will be aware from the committee
report that objection has been raised by
officers on the grounds that the
proposed works would not respect the
existing character and built form of the
dwelling
due to the development's large size and
elements such as lack of subservience
and terracing effect
the development would fail to form a
cohesive and attractive addition to the
building and would detract from the
overall appearance of the dwelling
and surrounding area it is also
considered that
the proposed development would fail to
preserve or enhance the character and
appearance of the distracted unhaven
conservation area
and less than substantial harm would be
caused
no public benefits are considered to
arise as a result of the proposed
development that would outweigh this
harm
in addition it is considered that the
first floor side extensions by way of
their size and sighting
would result in a material loss of
amenity for the occupiers of two and
four
garden row by way of loss of light and
outlook for the
for the first floor side facing bedroom
windows that look towards the property
it is also considered the number one ely
gardens
would also suffer from an overbearing
impact as a result of the proposed
development
chairman there are no updates and
chairman the application is recommended
for refusal
for the three reasons stated in the
officers committee report
thank you neil thank you very much for
that thorough presentation
um we will move straight to our first
speaker who is our applicant
mr chris howard mr howard are you there
you may need to press star 6 to unmute
your phone
and we will be able to hear you
hopefully
hello hello mr howard how are you
could i just point out there was a few
inaccuracies there in
where the numbers of the build where
what the um
planner was actually pointing out mr
howard if
you're welcome to point those
inaccuracies out um but i
must insist that they are during your
three-minute presentation
okay okay
yeah um it may be that someone asks a
question that you may be able to answer
but we'll see um so you've got three
minutes we'll give you a 30 second
warning
and whenever you're ready to go please
do commence
thank you um this was originally a row
of terraced cottages running
perpendicular to scholars lane up a
private drive
not visible to the public or the
conservation area
sorry um to the rear eli gardens a group
of high-density
three-story townhouses overbearing on
our much lower
much lower one and a half story house if
you look at photo a
and c the house is currently out of
balance
both visually and practically it does
not function well
we are not seeking to make it we are now
seeking to make it suitable for today's
standards we're making effective use of
the land
and i'm quoting planning policy 117 118
cde
which is helping to meet our needs as as
we are a multi-generation family living
in the same house
due to the high cost of accommodation in
stratford planning policy 2.7 meeting
the needs of the present without
compromising future
generations to meet their own needs plus
planning policy
910 core strategy 20.5.6.3
we propose to build onto the existing
single story wings
they may be demolished if they have to
but we do propose to build on
if possible putting back what was
originally there which was
a terrorist house to balance the house
with equal rooms on both floors
reference again
planning policy 117 118 which refers to
the effective use of land
use airspace above existing buildings
and helping to preserve our garden
amenity
we have support from town council from
the town council
gen uh councillor jenny fredsley and
both garden row residents
that's the neighbours regarding showing
subservience overbearing and loss of
light we have compared
complied lowering the height of the
extensions to the front
the original mono pitch roof means the
internal height of the rear is under
five
feet virtually unusable the rear of the
property is not visible in the
conservation area and is partly over and
is part overlooked by an overbearing
three-story gable end of one eli gardens
photo d visually this would be improved
with our extension to the front
photo a regarding privacy
we can currently look at our first floor
window directly into the rear garden of
one eli
our proposed extension would actually
give privacy to one eli and prevent
overlooking photo b
regarding loss of light to two garden
road there is a there will be a 4.8
meter gap between
our first floor and theirs and we are
situated to the north
i would say zero loss of light for
garden room this is a garden road this
room is much closer but it has another
window contrary to what the planner
pointed out
to the west both these rooms in two and
four are very small
low four foot at the lowest they're
barely box rooms
the neighbors are in support privacy
will also be improved everybody wins
i would hope to see consistency in
planning outcomes
if you consider what has recently been
approved by this council and built in
our vicinity we are surrounded by
three-story development none of which
would meet the criteria
being applied to our proposal and would
certainly not fulfill the statement by
the planner
extra sensitive conservation area photo
e and f
and all that yeah we are totally
overlooked
talk about overbearing we've got
overbearing care home with windows
overlooking our garden we're not over
building on our garden our garden
is far bigger than any of the gardens
you can see from the plan
and we're not extending into our
footprint um
we are building on top of what is
already exist and actually replacing
what was there
mr howard i'm going to have to ask you
to draw to a close there i'm afraid that
was your
three minutes okay thank you thank you
very much for that members do we have
any questions for mr howard
i'll give you a couple of seconds to
indicate in the chat
no okay in that case mr howard thank you
very much for your time and your
contribution if you want to press star
sex to mute yourself again
you can continue to listen that way or
if you want to log into our online
portal you can
uh watch the the final bits of
proceedings uh through that
um probably easier to do the latter but
thank you very much for your time
thank you okay we will move to our uh
next weekend final speaker for the
evening which is councillor jenny
franklin
councillor frankly you're there okay can
you hear me welcome
yeah we can yeah you have you have five
minutes you know drill you've got five
minutes 30 seconds warning
feel free to use as much or as little as
the five minutes as you wish thank you
very much
may i just start off by saying i think
some of the drawings gave a very
biased view where you had the original
drawing
in a white in a black outline
and then you have those very heavy red
extensions on both sides
i think the impact of these two
extensions will not be as overbearing as
was suggested in those drawings
this application has had a bit of an
uncomfortable history
due in maine to the upheavals of covid
it was validated on the 17th of the
second
2020. it's had two officers dealing with
it so far
and a third officer presenting this
evening
three garden row is a delightful small
one
could almost say tiny cottage one of
four
cottages on a secluded track off
scholars lane in the conservation area
number three was once at a two storied
cottage and part of a terrace it was two
cottages
two storied and part of the terrace it
was altered around 1900
to become one habitation and lost part
of its first story
these two small extensions replaced to
an
extent in the original configuration
the reasons for refusal are really based
around overlooking
and overbearing and inappropriate in the
conservation area
looking at the front elevation the
modest extension to the left
does not overlook eli gardens as it has
no windows to enable overlooking
the eye level of the the eve level is a
little higher than the original central
section
this is to allow an average height
person to stand close to the outside
wall
this cannot be done at the moment making
the room cramped and awkward
i do not think this extension is
overbearing
because as the roof slopes away
in line with the original roof so there
is a sense of space and
air when you look at the back elevation
that roof slopes away
neither is light compromised to
neighboring properties
as the house faces east and the back
elevation faces west
so that the sun tracks around uh to the
left ensuring good light and little
overshadowing to eli gardens
in fact it's stated in the papers that
this is not a mater
this is not material harm the small
extension to the right
is completely dwarfed by the massive end
gable of eli gardens which was given
permission in the conservation area by
this authority
this extension is intended to be a
bathroom and the small window indicated
will be obscured glass
and opens 2.8 meters from the blank wall
which you have seen
the slight rise in the eave height once
more allows an average height person to
stand close to the new wall
i'd like you to note that the the new
ridge levels
are subservient to the original part of
the building
please note that these are quite quirky
cottages
and i think the slight alteration in the
eave heights on the back
will not be a material should not be a
material consideration
to refusing this application
i note that the neighbors to both sides
positively support this application
mr howard has already replaced windows
in the front of his property with
hardwood frames
and has every intention to complete this
small development
with quite high quality materials in a
sensitive and respectful manner
thus enhancing the conservation area
with an historic cottage
restored to 21st century living
standards
i would just actually ask if you have
any doubts about this
i think you should have a visit to the
site so that you can see
the smallness of the cottage and the
the way it is the existing house is over
is very much overbeared by the eli
gardens
and the two very small extensions i
believe will have little impact
on the conservation but a great impact
on the family life of mr howard
thank you
councillor frangie thank you very much
for that well within your time
members do we have any questions for
councillor fragility please
i will give you a couple of seconds to
type into the chat
it looks like that is a no so counselor
frankly thank you very much for your
contribution once again if you if you
want to stay on and watch just make sure
your
your microphone is muted uh you're more
than welcome to hang around
okay um so that's our speakers for this
evening so
of two points of clarification to the
officer
members do we have any points for
clarification
one i'm waiting for anyone to write in
the chat uh neil i wonder if you could
um just give me a bit more of an idea
about the
the rooms at number four and number two
the bedrooms that
uh you allude to being over there uh
having an overbearing nature on them
yeah you've applied the various angle
rules and meterage rules and what have
you could you just recap those for me so
that
i'm fully cognizant of them
let me just share the um
can you see that on the
can you see on the screen the yeah we
certainly can yes thank you okay great
let me get the the photographs which is
probably the
so um so these are the these are the two
windows
in question so uh number four
so this this serves a um
a bedroom and i understand that there is
one other secondary
window that serves the bedroom as well
which is uh
which is obscure glazed and it's it's a
judgment call
that an officer will make in terms of
the
proximity
of the extension going in there and its
relationship to that window
so it's a judgment call that would that
an officer will make and and given the
close proximity
of that particular extension to that
window
um the judgment has been made that it
would it would
result by a by way of loss of or loss of
light and
outlook for the first floor side facing
window
and the same would apply
to number two although i do accept that
there is further there is greater
degree of separation between the
extension to the side and that window
and my understanding is that window is
the only window that serves that bedroom
okay thank you and just as a follow-up
to that we've
been it's been alluded to that we have
two uh letters of
um support from those two neighbors
obviously in our report we just see two
letters of support it doesn't say who
from
yeah can you confirm it has come from
number two and number four
uh and indeed what weight we should be
giving to that
given it's their windows that would
otherwise be either blocked or
overlooked
yes i can i can confirm that the letters
are
both from um the occupiers
of those properties so either side
they've supported the
the application that that is true um
obviously that third party
representations
are are given weight in the
decision-making process
however as officers we have to take that
into account and also
from the assessment that we that we
undertake
in terms of the planning assessment of
which part of them
part of that is the impact on the
amenity of the
um adjoining properties so
it's um so it's up to the
the decision maker to give the the
weight that they
that they feel to those um letters but
as
um as officers um
as as is detailed in the committee
report the concern is
that notwithstanding the comments from
the adjoining neighbours
the impact will be detrimental in those
two properties
okay thank you i guess um you're not
just looking at the
existing uh owners and residents of uh
number two number four it's
it's the impact that it could have on
future owners of it as well
yeah i can see yes i can see our
planning manager has indicated he'd like
to make a comment on this so richard if
you'd like to come in at this point
thank you chair um if it was exactly
that point i was going to make that we
are here to protect the property not the
resident
of that property um and whilst neil says
quite rightly that we give a level of
weight to um
the people who are there now what
they've said it is the property we have
to protect and i think
um that the um you asked about the 45 25
degree tests
i think it would breach both both of
those uh it would certainly breach the
45 because they're both head-on
uh and the northerly one at number four
would probably would breach the 25
i can't be sure on the window at number
two though
okay lovely thank you very much for that
um we have two more questions one from
councillor dixon so council dixon when
you're ready
thank you chairman um neil uh
questions regarding the the height of
the proposed
extensions on either side uh councillor
frasery was indicating that
they are subservient to the rich i think
i read in the report
they are only slightly subservient
um when we're looking at extensions
which ought to be subservient should we
be noticeable
from the ground to the passerby that
they are subservient
and not merely a matter of a few
centimeters
and uh i don't suppose there's any way
of knowing whether or not those letters
uh i've come from tenants or from owners
um in respect of your of your first
point um
counselor um
in terms of of subservience it it would
it would something that you'd you'd want
to um note
as um that
you know it would be noticeable so that
the when you looked
you know at the property so that you
would see that it would be
it would be subservient to the main to
the main dwelling effectively
i think the judgment that the officers
have made here is that
with only a 150 millimeter set down
um where it meets the ridge at the front
of the property
that that wouldn't give the impression
of of of being subservient to the main
dwelling
so i accept it is it is the judgment
call
but officer's judgment is that that that
wouldn't be subservient
um in in terms of the
um the letters um
i'll be perfectly honest with you i
don't know whether they are from the
from the um from the owner or or an
occupier i suspect they are from the
from the owners um but i couldn't i
couldn't be 100 sure of that
thank you thank you neil thank you both
uh we have a question now from
councillor adam councillor adam when
you're ready
thank you um it was one it's
maybe related to that somewhat um i know
that certainly when we're looking at
say in greenbelt locations it's about
visibility from public rights away
things like that
based on the photos i've seen it's it's
hard to see from when you're standing
right next to it let alone from the road
nearest that isn't private um so i'm
wondering how
how much that plays into it um as it and
it does appear that
subservient or not it would be
very hard to see um and i'm not sure how
much weight that should be afforded in
this case but
could you still clear that up for me
um yes i mean it's
um it's more a um
it's a judgment in terms of the of of
the design
um and and what
what officers are are are looking to see
is is is for
the um for the extension to be to be
subservient to the main
to the main part of the house so that's
so that it isn't the dominating factor
essentially um i mean that that
that will be able to be viewed in the in
the street scene i
i accept here um that
um the public views
are somewhat limited by the by the
location of the
of the building and and and and the
surrounding area
um but officers would make would make a
judgment in terms of the in terms of the
design
and the overall appearance and the
impact of that on the overall appearance
of the building
and as you can see from the committee
report
officers are not in agreement
that that what is proposed is acceptable
okay thank you thank you um
you're breaking out reports at the
moment
i'm not sure we can't really hear you
all that well
okay uh i can try a little bit longer
how's that that's better
okay i'll try and be brief um i'm not
sure
um
there's one family i think that
mentioned multiple generations from one
family living in
in this one property uh given the
current um covered 19
pandemic which we've agreed in previous
applications is a material planning
matter
to some extent um does
the livability of the property uh given
current circumstances have
um significant weight in the planning
process at this time
especially considering the um
the the matters that were raised by the
applicant in terms of
how how practical it is to live within
the house in its current state
would you like me to respond to that
chair i'm not sure he's now with us
yes sorry yes by all means please do
okay um yeah obviously the kobe 19
crisis
is a material consideration um but that
has to be
weighed against the lifespan of the
properties and lifespan of the
extensions
which would uh far outlive the current
crisis
uh and for that reason i would give any
benefits of living
arrangements uh limited weight because
of the short period that would have
um persist full compared to the long
period
that the extensions um and any harm that
would result from them
would exist for okay understand thank
you very much both
yeah thank you all for that uh we do
have uh three more questions
uh for officers so first of all
councillor hunter serafin please
yes thank you chair uh neil
can you tell me how far the windows
are around uh distance from the new
development
do you have a measurement for those
from the existing
um what would the distance be from those
two windows to the new development
let me see if i can just
just trying to find the right plan to
let me see if i can um
if i can zoom in here
because i think looking at number four
the width of the extensions
are quoted on
the plans here let me just have a look
um let's see if they're on here
would it be helpful if i perhaps
was able to measure them
yeah they look quite far away to me
i think when you i think what a sort of
useful one to look at is perhaps um
let me see if i can
in terms of the proximity if we can zoom
in
here you can see the red line next to
the adjoining property there
number number four and you can see
that that is is very close to the
to the boundary there neil i'm just
sorry i'm going to interrupt you at the
moment
it troubles me that this this diagram
whilst very helpful in your indications
is a little bit of guesswork
um we're not getting to the actual
answer um yeah would you mind
do you have the facility to be able to
measure uh now um and while you do that
i'll bring in the other two questions
and perhaps um
either you'll be able to answer whilst
you're measuring or uh richard gardner
may be able to answer those would that
be okay
okay yeah sure so um castorgenics do you
want to come in with your question at
this point please
thank you chairman unfortunately i think
my question may be to neil and i think
he's a bit busy because i was
i just wanted to know how much dialogue
the applicant has had with the officers
on the design of this and how much did
they take on board the officer's
thoughts on it and did they
were they very willing to start changing
was there a lot of dialogue there
okay neil are you in a position to
answer that whilst you're measuring or
should we bring the next question then
we can recap them both before you answer
um i think the the the answer to that
chairman is i i i honestly don't know
because i i wasn't
the um i wasn't the case officer for it
if the uh if the truth be told
um i i don't know whether
sorry i don't know whether it's on the
case file to see what level of
correspondence
has been if that would help
if you would be great
uh
so there are there are some um there are
some superseded plans on
on the file so there has obviously been
some
correspondence um between the the
applicant and the district council
with a view to amending the original
plans to um
to make them more more acceptable and i
could bring
those up if that would be helpful
chairman
i'm not sure it's necessary to see
superseded plans to be honest we've got
the
appropriate plans that we're deciding on
in front of us yes yeah
so my question was really just to work
out how much dialogue they've been
so obviously there has been a third
degree of correspondence and dialogue
thank you i think it's fair to say
evidently there has been some
um it's impossible for us to quantify
because we don't have
uh the original case officer uh to hand
so
actually i think we'll leave that
question there um
have you had an opportunity to measure
yeah i'm just um i'm just having a look
at the plans
if i can come back i've got the
measurements on the
existing um
on the existing floor plans if that
would
if that would help some indication
[Music]
so can you see the
can you see those on the we can you can
okay
so in terms
of
so if we just go here so you can see the
width
of the extension there
which is close to the boundary which is
effectively 2.875 meters
the width there and the other side be
3.278
meters in terms of the width so that's
the area that it will be
that it will be taking up in terms of
the width and
proximity to the to the adjoining
property it might just be worth
just going back to the photographs that
i showed previously as well
do you do you have neil yeah i am on
muted sorry i thought i hadn't
understood myself
do you do you have an aerial uh image of
the site
and we can get a reasonable
understanding i think from that yeah
we don't have plans to measure yeah what
i have got
is can you see that plan there
we can so this
i'm not quite sure when this was taken
because i think it's before the care
home came in
but what you can see here is um
so you have two and four and that's the
application site three there so that's
the ground floor which is to be
demolished and built up to second floor
level and that's approximately the
location of the window that i showed
before
and then that's where the first floor
extension is going to go
and that's easy gardens there number one
okay are you able to um zoom in
uh on the application site and include
if you can
number two and number four that will
help us get a better understanding of
their proximity
let me
does that help at all it certainly helps
me i'm going to
uh ask peter uh sorry counselor hencha
seraphin
if that has helped obviously we haven't
got the
plans to measure right now so we can't
get an exact gap between the two
but does that give you an understanding
of the proximities just a second
mr gardner yes it does help slightly yes
but uh still not totally specific
okay okay no you know
okay then that's okay neil thank you
okay thank you
um mr gardner did you want to make a
comment at that point
um yes um as you've seen neil's unable
to measure it but what i would say based
on the measurements i've seen on the
plans compared to what i can see on that
on the northerly one close to number
four i would say it's
within a metre the bedroom window at
number four within a metre
of the development and on the southern
one the bedroom
at number two i would estimate
that to be within three meters of the
development
lovely thank you i think the point to
stress there is they are estimations
they are not
absolute numbers but we've got an
estimation and a
visual to help there in your
deliberations um
okay councillor fleming last question i
believe
yes thank you chairman um councillor
frankly was saying that this used to be
a row of terrorist cottages so at some
point or other
and that building line was as high as
the other part at some time in the past
um i know don't know if it's relevant
but how long has the building been like
this with these gaps in there anyway
um and unless i don't know if it's
actually relevant as to whether we fill
them in again
so i just wonder if that could if
anybody can answer that question
um i i think it's um it's addressed
in the um in the committee report under
impact on heritage assets and it talks
about um
it's been suggested by the applicant
that historically the building was fully
two-story and may have formed part of a
two-story terrace in this area
but it does go on to say however the
evidence submitted suggests this ceased
to be the case at least 100 years ago
and as this is long before any
conservation area appraisals were
carried out
in the area it's hard to assign this
fact any significant weight
so that that's the approach that
officers have taken in the
in the committee report
marvelous thank you i believe cancer
fragile also mentioned that it was in
1900 early 1900s so that accords with
the officer report
as well for anyone looking for that's on
page 44 of the report
okay uh i believe we have now covered
all of our questions
um and points of clarification to
officers um so we shall move
into the debate who would like to start
i believe councillor dixon may have
something he would like to say to
councillor dixon if you're ready would
you like to say it now
uh thank you chairman yes um i must
admit that
that aerial shock did produce another
concern
uh certainly um but basically i was
wondering that
admittedly we we don't meet in
elizabeth's house as frequently as we
would like to because of covid
but given that it's just around the
corner i'm thinking that
you know i wish the the ward member had
requested a site visit before we got to
this point
but i would personally like to see a
site visit because i think this is
really one
for trying to assess the impact of those
ridge heights
and whether or not we think it's going
to be subservient or not we can see the
position of those adjacent windows
but certainly that aerial shot to me
suggested that that
uh first ground ground floor at number
two
looks as though it's probably got some
skylights in the roof so
anything constructed by way of an
extension
adjacent to that would significantly i
think impact upon
number two but uh i would propose a site
visit i don't know if anybody would like
to second that
uh thank you very much for that council
dixon um would anyone else either like
to second
or speak councillor adam has come in uh
on the chat and seconded council adam
would you like to speak to your second
yes thank you and i think the the visual
impact and
and actually the the details of the site
as i raised as a question
to to officers is is clearly very
um poignant in in the determination of
this one and i think a site visit would
definitely
assist in that and and um and would
allow um members to to really make make
a better
informed decision so i'm very happy to
second that one
okay thank you very much would anyone
before we have a vote on that
uh would anyone like to make any further
comment
on either that proposal or on the uh on
the debate overall
counselor jennings
thank you chairman these these are what
i
we occasionally have these planning
applications which come in
and these are the ones which i
absolutely hate
um because
logic says we should do we should
we should change the rules
but unfortunately rules are rules
um you have to have a different
extension has to have a difference in
rich height
um so i thought i've never really
understood that one
or dem is the rules um
it's the the fact that is sort of
on one of the windows it's one meter
away
um whether it's two meters away it's
still
very overbearing and i don't know i
appreciate
it's one of it again it's one of these
things where the neighbors don't object
but it's not their comments obviously
are important but not it's to do with
the building
it's all about the r it's about the
rules and if we want to go
against the officers um
recommendations on this we have to give
very good
valid reasons to go against them and
the fact that i don't like it isn't
isn't sufficient
um so i'd be struggling to go against
the officer's
um recommendations on this one
okay thank you very much councillor
jennings is is that um i need to ask the
question is that a proposal to grant in
line with the
officer's recommendation or are you
holding off on that
i'm holding off on that for the time
being
okay understood thank you more comments
understood that we do have three people
who have indicated they want to speak
council dixon because you already have
i'm going to save you till last
um so i will bring in councillor kendall
first please
thank you chairman um i'm i'm struggling
with this one like council jennings was
saying
these these are the ones i don't like
either because it's very confusing and i
completely understand the
uh the needs of the applicants i can
understand that they want to adapt their
home to make it more usable more
uh more uh comfortable for them
as the years go on but i'm looking at
this there's the only thing
i can't get past this loss of light and
i i really do think that the office has
done a very good job
in assessing this uh in terms of the
loss of light and the overlooking
into the indus and they both neighbors i
think really
i don't i don't think i'm going to
benefit from site visit
on this one so i'm afraid i'll abstain
on the site visit to be honest
and i wouldn't i would support the
officer's recommendation of refuse
thanks i think thank you counselor
kendall just want to check with you is
that a proposal to
uh grant along with officer
recommendation or are you holding off on
that as well
um i'm happy to propose that we follow
the officer's recommendation of refuse
fabulous um so okay that's good thank
you very much
i'm going to second that um for the
reasons that both yourself counselor
kendall and councillor jennings have
given
um i just can't i can't get past
the the proximity to those windows and
whilst
whilst we have support from both number
two and number four that's the people
that live there now and as we've heard
from
our officers it's the buildings we're
trying to protect not the current
uh inhabitants of um and you know as
council journey said
them is the rules they are the rules and
they're there for a very good reason so
i
i just can't get around that so i've
seconded that i can see council jennings
has indicated his second
as well i'm sorry i've beaten you to it
um i do still have
i i also wouldn't benefit from a site
visit partly because i know the area
really well but also i've already
conducted a site visit so
i would be uh voting against that um
counselor eden has indicated he would
like to speak so counselor edwin john's
coming at this point
thank you chair um basically yourself
and counselor kendall has summarized my
thoughts as well i can't really get past
the light issue
um and for that reason i would have
seconded if everyone else hadn't so
thank you
marvelous thank you very much council
dixon i promise i'll come back to you so
you've got a comment you'd like to make
uh thank you chairman it was really um
it's perhaps
i did i do regard it as appropriate to
say it um
we don't have rules we have guidelines
um we have to
assess how much weight to give to the
various
aspects if we had rules you could put it
into a computer and that would come out
with the answer each time i'm sorry but
i need to
i need you to say that sorry
understood um yeah fine
i'm not gonna argue with you on that one
um okay
so we have two proposals we must
take the first proposal that was
seconded first
which is councillor dixon's to defer
pending a site visit i will start
the process um so council richards
against
councillor kenmore councillor kendall
against
councillor fleming chancellor fleming
against
councillor dixon councillor dixon 4
councillor eden
jennings
okay five against
chairman one two three four
i concur with that so uh committee
therefore uh
sorry that that proposal therefore fails
so we will move to our second proposal
which is to
refuse in line with the officer's
recommendation
i will go first councillor richards four
thank you councillor kendall councillor
kendall
four councillor fleming
coaster flowing reluctantly for
councillor adam councillor adam
against cancer dickson
councillor dixon abstain
councillor eden yes it's ready
for councillor henshaw seraphin
and sanchez seraphine against
councillor jennings councillor jennings
reluctantly for okay
one two three five four german two
against and one abstention fabulous
thank you very much ann
uh so committee therefore resolves to
refuse application twenty zero zero
four five four ful for the reason set
out in the officers
report members thank you very much for
your help this evening and your input
it has been invaluable uh officers
likewise to yourselves we have no urgent
business so i will then declare
the meeting to a close thank you very
much
thank you